for our next keynote speech it is my
great pleasure to invite Enrique Blanco
the global CTO of telefónica to deliver
his keynote presentation who better to
hear from about fiber deployment than
the actual doer of fiber deployment
achieving fantastic results in a Spanish
market and Rica the floor is yours thank
you thank you very much so first of all
thank you very much for this kind
invitation so proud to try to explain
what telefónica think about the fiber
deployment for sure in Spain but what we
are doing the worldwide operation and
when we are today so let me start so did
you see what means so there is a lot of
people that they are talking about fiber
in telefónica we are proud we do not
talk about fiber we are deploying fiber
and to deploy fiber it is not only to
get the technology it is not only to get
the capabilities in the terrain it is
refined processes it is refined tools it
needs to go much more close to the
customer it is still looking the
end-to-end approach of what fiber means
for the customer so a good example
Roland so Wi-Fi so maybe sometimes we
are not deploying fiber we had the
probing Wi-Fi for our customer so and
this applies the b2c and this applies to
the V to V so here is something who it
is clear for us this is the Spanish case
of the fiber the plane of telefónica
what had been the refere of telefónica
d'espagne so we were in 2011 around 1.6
millions of whom passes today we are up
to 20 million of whom passes in the
Spanish premises when we are operating
so this is what we have been doing with
the technical commercial stuff of
telefónica Hispania and with all our
partners that means contractors vendors
of technology and so on as a result of
this bigger food so if you compare when
telefónica in Spain it is
today so we have enough fiber if you
decide to compare we are you are Alvin
all the big countries of Europe so we
are bigger and we have a huge operation
more than they were having all the main
countries when we are in this is
evolution and this is an excellent
situation for the society digitalization
who finally it means how the customer
can perceive the access to the digital
services this is key for the society
development but which are the key
enables so because it is only to get the
technology it is only to get the
capabilities to buy technology now this
is mandatory but it is not enough so you
need to do something more first of all
how is pain it is today in the civil
engineering infrastructure and this mean
ducts and how we are managing these
ducts and trained to warranty that you
can reach with the external plant your
customer and telefónica has an excellent
position it is it because the investment
that telefónica had been doing in spain
in the past this is not lucky this is
effort this is capex the second one it
is a technology leadership so we have
been looking for all the technology look
in the best technology when at least it
doesn't exist we have been creating this
technology and I will be giving examples
following the Wi-Fi capabilities if the
technology doesn't exist we have been
working trying to do this technology
exist creating our own capabilities and
leading the industry return to warranty
that the customer perceives what fiber
means we have been analyzing when we
need to be and when we need to maintain
the knowledge in our own people so this
means tools processes knowledge and how
we can use the machine learning and the
capabilities of automatization of the
tools and how we can guarantee that the
operation will be successful in the past
if you see what happen in any other
countries there is a lot of people that
they try to do fiber deployment and
successfully this is not only technology
it is technology it is processors it is
no
it is to see this customer perspective
and customer approach for sure the
regulatory framework that have been
helping us trying to deploy never is
enough but we need to go because there
is still a percentage of customer that
need to be they need to read the fiber
and this is maybe the much more
difficult to do it
so how in Spain we have been managing
the convergence commercial approach so
with Russia on and how the market
consolidation had been pushed into the
market trend to deploy the fiber
capabilities if you see in the right so
which is the the one we are today so the
66% of the our customer they can
retrigger nan nega be symmetric our
equipment our equipment come fully
support up to 600 megabits but it is
what we have today Rowan so how many
customers they are getting TV approached
with some video capabilities and with
the capabilities trying to reach so this
excellent connectivity so how many
customer they are doing infusion and 91
percent of our customer - unique access
and this is absolutely mandatory trying
to offer our customer services fiber for
services so TV Wi-Fi excellent and so
one in telefónica we have fun obsession
it is how we can be much more efficient
so efficiency has no limits you can
improve always and we are in an
excellent condition
so trying to warranty that this is going
to happen today and in the future so if
you see how have been evolving they
connected coast and the passeth coast
for their fiber we had been doing an
excellent
so line so decreasing and decreasing and
decreasing getting bullion getting
processors getting to getting the right
partner getting training so putting
together all the skills that we need to
do trying to warranty that is happening
so we see today that go into the rest of
the country so the coast they will be
not going so good because we are going
to reach the much more difficult
customer
and it will be difficult trying to
written to maintain this line so but we
need to work from the technical point of
view trying to warranty that we will be
one of the key operators in terms of
Coast but this is not only for Spain so
we are you will see what we are doing
the rest of the countries and how we are
getting feedback trying to help to
maintain this line if this is feasible
when we decide that in Spain the fibre
it is key and the LT the ski so we took
it's actually the same coherent decision
for the rest of our operation so we
decide that all the operation when we
are today with the fix capabilities they
will be getting all the experience all
the knowledge all the capabilities all
the bender experience that we have in
Spain trying to go through the rest of
the market and then to get these
benefits so we have been offering to all
our operations so cross functional
end-to-end diastasis so it is key trying
to get a customer view from the point of
view of the network kpi's trying to
define what's about the global best
practices and this apply to the model
how you're managing your contractors how
you're managing your vendors how you're
managing your tools what's about the
train that you need to do to all the
technical guys that they are in the
field or in the customer premises and we
did it our room approach we have been
doing an alignment for all the operation
when we are getting the experience that
we have in Spain we are very proud
trying to work at a single company at a
global company so trying to warranty
that all the experience that we have in
Spain it is going to be translated to
the rest of the operation when we are
let me say telefónica it is not only
didn't in Spain the FT th deployment we
are living in Brazil we are living in
Argentina we are living in Chile and we
are living in Colombia because telephony
has a very very very clear thing in
fiber it is the future for our customers
and we cannot compete if we don't have
fiber approach
in the countries when we are operating
so this is applicable for a spin for
sure that they were living this project
but telefónica has a coherent and
consistent thinking and this is because
it you see so in 2017 with it more than
1.4 it millions 1.5 million of whom
passed in Brazil we are doing more than
half a million in Argentina and this
year we'll be doing around half a
million of home passes in Chile and if
you go to Chile did you go to Argentina
if you go to Brazil or you go to
Valencia in a custom and of telefónica
so it is exactly the same approach
descend the same end-to-end process the
same equipment the same customer
premises equipment so it is a global
operation when all the experience of
Spain it is helping us trying to go to
the rest of the country to offer a
better experience for our customer and
we had a feedback trying to help to all
the operation where this is not about
technology it is about how you are
operating your customer and what about
the customer experience it is the only
important because the customers contain
it is not acquiring fiber maybe sometime
there is quite an Wi-Fi in all the rooms
that they have at home and it is just
impossible to offer the quality he do
not have the father in the technology so
you can see that we have been reaching a
very similar quality that we have in
Spain in Brazil in less than nine months
maybe you can say that it is pure cost
reduction no it is quality of Hesperian
for the customer how you can divide the
complaints that the customer has how you
can do this in an end-to-end approach
and how do you are building a common
experience if you see we have been the
leverages in terms of the plasticity of
telefónica has been applying in all the
market getting all the experience for
sustained it is the loop contract
employee shinzo we have been working in
a single kind of contract so we don't
pay per activity maybe you say what
means fiber with how you do pay so it is
very important
you are looking for quality this is not
only the technology in the sternal plan
and and the rest it is how you are
managing the people that we are working
with your suppor so and we are migrating
in all the experience that we have in
Spain have been applied to the rest of
the countries so we have a quality plan
so in all the countries when we they are
starting we are very proud of this they
are looking what's about the quality of
Spain how we can get these numbers in
these KPIs and what are the levels that
the people of a Spain they are doing and
we are very proud because all the people
it is thinking as a single company into
Spain it is helping us trying to improve
clearly so tools so maybe you send that
the tools they are not technology the
tools they are so important and maybe
there are some companies that they try
to do some fibre deployment they fail
because I didn't have the tools and the
processes and telefónica it is an expert
we know that we are offering services
fiber it is an acronym moves fibers
means for sure be working with the key
vendors in the fiber capabilities in the
old iccup abilities so but fiber means
tools processes and people don't need to
get the right training trying to do it
we are using mature learning we are
using so all the capabilities and we are
reaching the artificial intelligence
trying to get all the information that
we have a fowl customer trying to
translate in the tools and trying to
offer and a special so experience for
all of us getting all the data being
used to improve the services that we are
doing our customer so we are applying
for the FTTH and we will for the fudgey
very soon I go back to your example so
it is once you are going to doesn't
matter which is a hotel doesn't matter
which is the home the first question of
millennial it is there is Wi-Fi so maybe
you don't know that you cannot have a
call but it the affair it is not really
or it is not so good so something is
wrong and the people it is not a skinny
this is fiber or not
it is asking for the Wi-Fi quality and
it was undated so more than the 80 or 85
percent of a total traffic that Ana
smartphone it is doing it is coming
through the Wi-Fi of the home premises
and the second spirit it is the customer
it is always using the best experience
in the network that leha's Wi-Fi
versus 4G or 5g it will be which is the
best experience for the customer and
will be successful the best experience
for the customer so this is something
clear for us and this is because that
that we decide that we were looking in
the industry looking the end-to-end
approach or the fiber deployment look
into the customer who it is the real
boss
so what he is asking for us when he is
ask him fiber he's asking for sure
quality for the TV and the content that
we are offering for sure and we need to
offer so a minimum amount of throughput
but he's asking and Wi-Fi experience at
home doesn't matter which is a room when
he is at this moment and this is because
we were looking what the industry is
offering us and the industry to be a to
be honest it is just only looking for
price but they are not looking for
quality and this is because telefónica
decide once we are doing with the fiber
so we are not offering fiber at home we
are offering an experience of a digital
capabilities supported by fiber at home
so we are fighting and we say hey
Telefonica it is present in handi dull
because we can offer our customer and
Wi-Fi absolutely unique when we are in
this mean that we need to go to offer
our customer so one single portfolio of
customer premises equipment trying to
warranty that we are offering the best
Wi-Fi approach doesn't matter when we
are doing in doesn't matter which is a
country with a single tin of four
devices that that we are applying in all
the countries when we are operating and
the initial experience and all the
capabilities they were born in Spain so
have been launched
for all the rest of the countries when
we are operating in today telefónica tis
de living in terms of quality with the
home gateway unit that it is putting
together the Ont and the routing
capabilities and we are building a
spirit sis offer our customer set-top
boxes with 4k experience in real
building so home port or repeaters of
Wi-Fi trying to warranty that our
customer if they are asking Wi-Fi
doesn't matter which is a rule we will
be offering for us it is key that the
experience digital experience means
quality throughput and not only this if
you see what's the technology that we
are building and sorry but we are
leading so because we were doing this
since 2012 so with this we are not
looking for cost reduction that finally
it is coming we were looking for quality
because the industry they do not offer
this one we had been building this kind
of iconic devices so today so three or
three years and a half later we start
with the deployment we can guarantee
that the incident rate using this
equipment versus the industry doesn't
matter which is the best practice it's
got to be reduces and 43% so this is
innovation or this is efficiency so you
decide porosity is a quality of
experience of the customer that has been
growing and we are going by the hand
reducing the cost because we don't need
to go to the customer premises trying to
do nothing because the device it is
working properly so the substitution
rate compared this device with the rest
of the industry it is 82% below the
industry this is quality this is not
course it is quality by the hand of the
innovation so and finally the
installation tain self insulin so
working very close to our partnered with
the contractor so have been reduces in a
41% this is not doing faster it is doing
better and we are controlling all the
chipset that we are introducing and all
the optical component that we are in
in this device and I'll go back this is
not for cost reduction this is for
innovation and quality in we can't
warranty that we can offer our customer
and an experience of 300 megabits
symmetric or 600 negative side matters
one we commercially site so in all the
customer premises when he is asking for
and we are working in our labs and we
are testing the main tips at provider of
Wi-Fi so working with two point four
five gigahertz and we will and all the
main functionalities that we are coming
from the industry we are testing and we
are the first testing because we have a
special agreement trying to achieve this
because fiber without this it is not
enough we can not warranty our customer
experience as we try to do it and this
is for Spain and this is for all the
rest of country when we are operating so
there is a lot of discussion of idea and
throughput and latency and they can be
substituting the the ftth so long
discussion this is not the moment
because the FTTH it is rowing and rowing
and rowing so and we are adapting or
recenter so we are today in Japan so but
we are working now in our labs and we
will launch in we are technical ready
trying to do it
detained upon and we are working in
doing the 25 people but this is the
access side this is the exercise so
today all our operation again starting
for the capabilities and experience on
the Spanish team we are building our
call trying to warranty that the
evolution of the access capabilities by
the hand of the LT 5g and FTTH growing
in throughput they can fully support all
the traffic growing that we have that it
is going to multiply by 2 gr over G R so
we are trying to simplify our operations
so so we are very active trying to work
how we can close our central office
don't forget that doesn't matter which
is the increment operators of our
central offices they have been built
looking the copper attenuation six seven
kilometers so circle central office and
this is one of our main asset that today
we are managing trying to close
following the regulatory issues
following the customer migration and so
on we have a very stress eight plan
trying to close or switch off central
offices because of fiber so in what we
are doing a full commitment of the
regulatory timings so we are trying to
close one per day so maybe this city's
very stressed but this is not enough and
we will be maintaining the written but
this is the matter of visible telephony
gate is doing an massive program trying
to reduce the complexity of the
transport layer reducing the complexity
reducing the transport capabilities
going through the WD and trying to fully
support so there is what you can see but
behind there is a still of activity
reducing the inventory in the complexity
getting efficiencies and finally getting
assets trying to warranty that we can
offer additional capabilities in the
access for our customer so telefónica
has a very bold plan trying to reduce
the energy so we have been winning so
the last prices in terms of how we can
guarantee that we are reducing the
carbon consumption in all our operations
so and we are leading because we knows
that the energy efficiency doesn't
matter it is applicable to the basis
station doesn't matter it is applicable
to our central offices it is hit rent to
warranty the sustainability in the
future of this operation so and the last
topic it is we are managing the
virtualization and we commit in the
Mobile World Congress of Barcelona in
2012 so today we do not have quite
nothing in terms of simulation or
control doesn't matter it is for the
mobile or the other fix so it is not
built all I said so maybe this was a
dream five years ago today
it's a fact and all the industry is
going for this but we have our own
program of utilization that we are
trying to industrialize and this is
going to be adapted how we can guarantee
that the visualization it is a fact
because with this we can guarantee the
5g evolution in the next 2-3 years so
once we are doing a massive deployment
of this was the commercial and the
spectrum capabilities they can guarantee
to the technical thing trying to do it
so today nothing in the FTTH it is not
going to be built well I said if this is
something that this help in trying to
control on to manage the civilization so
fiber it is more than technology we need
all these we need Ont technology we need
customer premises equipment we need all
the vendors that you can see out so
getting all the new best practices so we
are at choir in a global perspective but
fiber and technology it is not enough it
is customer behavior it is processes it
is tools and if you're asking me how
will be the key trying to guarantee the
successful and how we can go close to
the customer it is using the
capabilities in the tools in the machine
learning in the intelligent artificial
train to simplify how the customer it is
doing the interaction with Telefonica
that will be helping us trying to really
do a massive and profitable operation so
this is what we are trying to do so this
is what we try to explain humble but
this is what we are doing living when
the technology it is not so being in a
massive way when it is really and we can
simplify so and this is what I try to
share with you so try and explain when
we are so and thank you very much for
your attention
you